where we left off in the last video we
were finding the surface area of a torus
or a doughnut shape and we were doing it
by taking a surface integral in order to
take a surface integral we had to find
the partial of our parameterization with
respect to s and the partial with
respect to T and now we're ready to take
the cross-product and then we can take
the magnitudes of the cross product and
then we can actually take this double
integral and figure out the surface area
so let's just do it step by step
here we could take the cross-product
which is not a non hairy operation this
is why you don't see many surface
integrals actually get done or many
examples done so let's take the cross
product of these two fellows so the
partial of R with respect to s crossed
with in magenta the partial of R with
respect to T this will be a little bit
of a view of cross products for you you
might remember this is going to be equal
to the determinant the determinant I'm
going to write the unit vectors up here
of the first rows I J and K and then the
next two rows are going to be let me do
that in that yellow color the next two
rows the next two rows are going to be
the components of these guys so let me
copy and paste them you have that right
there let me copy and paste put that guy
right there then you have this fellow
right there copy and paste put them
right there and then you got this guy
right here this will save us some time
copy and paste put them right there and
the last row is going to be this guy's
components copy and paste put them right
here and almost done
this guy copy and paste put them right
there make sure we know that these are
separate terms and finally we could if
we don't have to copy and paste it but
just since we did it for all of the
other terms I'll do it for that zero as
well so the cross product of these is
literally the determinant of this matrix
right here right here it's this
determinant it's that determinant and so
just sort of a bit of a refresher of
taking two
permanence this is going to be I times
the sub determinant right here if you
cross out this column in that row so
it's going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to I you're not
used to seeing the unit vector written
first but we can switch the order later
times I times the sub matrix right here
if you cross out this column in that row
so it's going to be this term times 0
which is just 0 minus this term times
that term so minus this terms times this
term the negative signs are going to
cancel out so this will be positive so
it's just going to be I times this term
times this term without a negative sign
right there so I times this term which
is a cosine of s it's really that term
times that term minus that term times
that term but the negatives cancel out
that times that is 0 so that's not we
can do it so it's a cosine of s times
times B plus a cosine of s I'll just all
switch to the same color sine of T so we
got our I term for the cross product now
it's going to be plus actually minus J
you remember when you take the
determinate you actually have this kind
of you have to checkerboard of switching
signs so it's now it's going to be minus
J minus J times so you cross out that
row in that column and it's going to be
this term times this term which is just
0 minus this term times this term and
once again when you have oh sorry it's
quote when you cross out this column and
that row so it's going to be that guy
it's going to be that guy times that guy
- this guy times this guy so it's going
to be minus this Tikes times this guy so
it's going to be let me do it in yellow
so the negative times negative that guy
B plus a cosine of s cosine of T times
this guy a cosine of s a cosine of s
we'll clean it up in a little bit
immediately well we'll clean this up and
you see this this negative and that
negative will cancel out we're just
multiplying everything
and then finally the K term so plus I'll
go to the next line plus K times cross
out that row that column it's going to
be that times that minus minus that
times that so that looks like a kind of
a beastly thing but I think if we take
step by step it shouldn't be too bad so
that times that the negatives are going
to cancel out so we have this term right
here is going to be a sine of T sine of
s and then this term right here is B
plus a cosine of s sine of T sine of T
so that's that times that and the
negatives canceled out that so I didn't
put any negatives here minus this times
this so if you this times this is going
to be a negative number but if you take
the negative of it it's going to be a
positive value so it's going to be plus
plus that a cosine of T sine of s times
that times B plus a cosine of s cosine
of T now you see why you don't see many
examples of surface integrals being done
let's see if we can if we can clean this
up a little bit especially especially if
we can clean up this last term a bit so
let's see it what we can do to simplify
it so our first term so let's just
multiply it out I guess is the easiest
way to do it actually the easiest first
step would just to be factor out the B
plus a cosine of s because that's in
every term B plus a cosine of s B plus a
cosine of s B plus a cosine of s B plus
a cosine of s so let's just factor that
out so this whole crazy thing can be
written as B plus a cosine of s so we
factored it out times I'll put in maybe
put some brackets here so you know it
multiplies times every component so the
I component we need to factor this guy
out is going to be a cosine of s sine of
T let me write it in green so that's
going to be a cosine of s sine of T a
cosine of s sine of T times I you're not
used to seeing the eye before it so I'm
going to write the eye here and then
plus plus we're factoring this guy out
so you're just going to be left with
cosine of T a cosine of s or we can
write it as a cosine of s cosine of T
that's that right there just putting it
in the same order as that times the unit
vector J and then when we factored this
guy out so we're not going to see we're
not going to see that or or that anymore
when we factor that out we can multiply
this out and what do we get so in green
I'll write again so plus so if you
multiply sine of T times this thing over
here because that's all that we have
left after we factor out this thing we
get a a sine of s sine of s sine squared
of T right we have sine of T times sine
of T sine squared of T so that's that
over there plus what do we have over
here we have a sine of s times cosine
squared of T a sine of s times cosine
squared of T and all of that times the K
unit vector all of that times the K unit
vector and so things are looking a
little bit more simplified but you might
see something jump out at you you have a
sine squared and a cosine squared so
somehow if I can just make that just
sine squared plus cosine squared of T
those will simplify to one and we can we
can in this term right here we can if we
just focus on that term and this is all
kind of algebraic manipulation if we
just focus on that term if we just focus
because this term right here can be
rewritten as a sine of s if we factor
that out times sine squared of t plus
cosine squared of T times our unit
vector K right I just factored out an a
sine of s from both of these terms
this is our most fundamental trig
identity from the unit circle this is
equal to one so this last term
simplifies to a sine of s times K so so
far we've gotten pretty far we were able
to figure out the cross product of these
two
I guess partial derivatives of the
vector value to our original
parameterization there we were able to
figure out what this thing this thing
right here before we take the magnitude
of it it translates to this thing right
here let me let me rewrite it well I
don't need to rewrite it you know that
well I'll rewrite it so that's equal to
I'll rewrite it neatly and we'll use
this in the next video B plus a cosine
of s times open bracket a cosine of s
sine of T times I plus switch back to
the blue plus a cosine of s cosine of T
times J plus switch back to the blue
this thing Plus this simplified nicely a
sine of s times K times the unit vector
K this this right here is this
expression right there and I'll finish
this video since I'm already over ten
minutes and in the next video we're
going to take the magnitude of it and
then if we have time actually take this
double integral and we'll all be done
we'll figure out the surface area of
this torus